so with Trump running so you don't think
they're going to be able to stop them
they're going to try to figure out many
creative ways but knowing Trump and
you've spent a lot of time with them
you're your feeling is that he's most
likely if he runs uh he doesn't feel
neither one of those stores are going to
get in the way
right I think for Trump it's really a
double whammy number one this is a guy
who hates to lose this is also a guy who
who's willing to lose but if he feels
that he was cheated you know he is
looking for Vindication I mean for him
it's it's just as much about vindicating
the Trump name and his sort of his that
so so this is why I think nothing will
stop him he's going to want the only way
to stop him is sort of somehow to
physically prevent him from being able
to do it
um locking him up something like that
which the left I think is willing to do
they're they're they are terrified about
this guy there's a little bit of hope
that maybe like maybe the Sanders will
challenge Trump maybe you know and there
are a few Republicans who take the view
that DeSantis is basically Trump but
with less hassles you it doesn't have
the some of the weaknesses of trump or
he won't bring some of the baggage to
Trump and I think that may be true but
here's the other side of it and that is
that it's it's a um it's it's what I
call animal magnetism you know one time
F Scott Fitzgerald the writer was asked
you know do you think you have a
privileged life and he said well he goes
I don't have the best two things in life
but I've got the second best two things
he goes I've got looks and I've got
intelligence but he goes the best two
things in life to have our money and
animal magnetism and by animal magnetism
he was actually thinking about Ernest
Hemingway where Ernest Hemingway could
go to Spain he's in the bull fight
suddenly you know he's on the you know
he's there with the bull I mean the
Spanish are like cheering Hemingway he
had that kind of so Trump has that if
you have a big room DeSantis walks in
let's just say he just walks in as an
ordinary guy not a single head will move
Trump walks in all heads turn Reagan had
the same so that animal magnetism that
Trump has is very difficult if you don't
have it there's no easy way to get a wow
factor it's the wow factor so so if if
these two both run most likely you're
thinking they're both gonna run Trump
and the scientist no I think actually
descent is very cleverly is positioning
himself to either run with Trump or to
run the next time around with yeah with
Trump or the next time around so in
other words Trump DeSantis that would be
the ticket
yeah you think that's a likely scenario
because a lot of people say that the you
know they're both number ones and you
know you can only have one CEO of a
company there's no co-ceo yeah but
that's only true at one time in other
words you can have one CEO but Trump can
only run for four years and DeSantis has
his whole life ahead of him so for
DeSantis it's ultimately about when is
the best time to make that Lifetime move
is it do you want to run against Trump
where first of all the you know the base
of the Republican party is very trumpian
it's going to be kind of hard to beat
Trump now with that base
um on the other hand if DeSantis went in
and came in as a vice president he would
be the automatic presumptive
front-runner Trump would be off the
stage so if I were to scientist that's
what I would do sure but that that's you
know like even with Biden and Kamala he
chose Kamala you know after the primary
or after the the Republican RNC meaning
that was DNC apologize that was after
the debates okay so are you saying that
um this Santas won't even go on the
debate stage I'm just kind of waiting
the wings for Trump to win and then just
be like all right I'll be your your
lucky little VP because I see him
getting on that stage don't you no I I
think I think they'll I if I again if
I'm the way I'm thinking and I've been
following politics now very closely for
a long time there there are different
ways to pick a VP when Reagan ran in
1980 Reagan picked Bush Reagan didn't
even know Bush so why did he pick bush
bush was the second highest vote getter
in the Republican party it was The
Logical Choice it didn't matter to
Reagan I don't know him
um he goes I'm gonna pick my number two
he's he's gonna be the guy most likely
to carry me over the top so now ask
yourself who's the guy most likely to
help carry Trump over the top and
convince even doubting Republicans that
here's a competent elected official that
kind of knows how to cross the t's and
Dot the eyes that will help Trump with
some of what may be seen as Trump's
weaknesses and the obvious guy is the
Santa's he knows how to run a state
what's so funny Pat oh my God if if that
I I
yeah I don't know I don't know but if
that were to happen
let me tell you I mean it's it's a
nightmare for the left for 12 years if
that were to happen for 12 years
the the left will need to see their
therapist two or three times a week
instead of the one a week yeah it's it's
because they're both Vindication type of
guys both of them are yeah the santis is
so is Trump you don't want those two to
be your opponent for 12 years uh they're
they're not the type of people that are
going in just to you know there's
different types of people in life
there are those that are resume chasing
resume Chasers want to be able to say I
worked at Google I worked at Amazon I
worked under XYZ I worked under this
person there's resume Chasers that go
get their PHD or Masters or MBA just to
say I got a masters I gotta this there's
resume Chasers that want to go to Oxford
or Yale or Harvard to say I went there I
went to Wharton the resume Chasers right
they're resume Chasers that eventually
just want to be CPAs or CFOs or CEOs one
time just to say I was
and then you got guys that are Crusaders
and True Believers that are not chasing
a title or resume and as DeSantis and
Trump neither one of those guys are
chasing that Biden for the rest of his
life will be a president that's just
going to be in the history books he's a
resume Chaser he for the rest of his
life's gonna be that there's people like
that on the left there's people like
that on the right there's people like
that in sports there's people like that
in politics there's people like that in
churches there's people like that
everywhere not these two families these
two guys are very weird very different
you do not want there's certain people
in life you don't want as enemies those
two you don't want as enemies if that
were to happen which I don't know if
that would happen because
in a perfect world like are you selling
this or are you saying this based on
Insight or are you saying this based on
I think this will happen what's your
position when you're saying this yeah
I'm not advocating it I think it will
happen okay guys and the reason I'm
saying it is not again this is not my
field I'm not a pollster I'm not a but
what what it is it's just based upon the
observation there are certain natural
laws in politics as in foreign policy
right for example years ago when I was
in in college a professor of mine said
look let's look at the map of the world
okay and let's forget about communism
and capitalism and left wing and right
wing and let's just look at the the
world is divided into big blobs and
small blobs they're big countries
they're big blobs big circles then
they're small countries around them
those are small blobs now based upon
just looking at the world like that and
knowing nothing about it you're from
Mars can you predict how this world will
shake out which which countries would be
allied with which countries which
countries will be fighting with which
countries and the truth of it is you can
have a whole seminar where you see that
the big countries are all rivals and the
small countries now Ally with the big
countries near them to become in order
to get protection but other small
countries that were likely to be gobbled
up will try to find big countries
elsewhere that can support them and then
you look at the world and it's happening
like that you know so similarly when you
look at American politics and you say to
yourself everyone's thinking in terms of
their own self-interest and if you if
you look at DeSantis and you say I just
okay I'm this antis I'm the number two
guy do I actually want to run against
the number one guy right now and run the
risk where If I Lose I'm bruised enough
that other people now start coming to
the front and the sort of Maga mentality
will now so that the next time around it
may be Kerry Lake I don't want that I
want to make sure that I am the only guy
that is on the inside track and nobody
will even dare to challenge me the way I
do that is I essentially go into Trump's
tent recognizing that for Trump there's
only one more time to go around the
block so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]